now as we mentioned earlier in the
program the prime minister's going to
belfast this week to urge the parties
there to come to an agreement and get
the power sharing institutions back up
and running the assembly is currently
gridlocked because the dep won't take
part until the northern ireland protocol
is changed or dropped now that of course
is likely to spark an almighty row with
the eu and some countries have already
threatened a trade war if the uk acts
unilaterally well let's go live to cork
now we can talk to ireland's foreign and
defense minister simon coveny thank you
very much for being with us this morning
and now you've written in the sunday
telegraph today to say i'm deeply
concerned for the well-being of the
partnership between our countries can
you just explain your concerns
well first of all just to to correct
something that you've said the eu hasn't
threatened anything not a trade war and
not anything else what the eu wants is
partnership so that we can work together
to resolve the issues that remain
in relation to the protocol which of
course was designed to try to manage the
disruption of brexit on the island of
ireland
so the last thing the eu wants the last
thing that ireland wants
is tension with the uk particularly at
the moment given the
uh what's happening in ukraine russian
aggression and the need to work together
on an international stage
but unfortunately it has been the
briefings that has come from the british
government this week
that has raised a real red flag in
dublin and in brussels
because the british government is now
threatening to break international law
to break a treaty that they signed with
the eu and that they designed with the
eu
and ratified with a huge majority in the
house of commons
and in doing so
uh potentially creating huge problems on
the island of ireland
and while there are issues that need to
be resolved in relation to the
implementation of the protocol there are
concerns within the unionist community
in particular that need a comprehensive
response the way to do that isn't for
the british government to act
unilaterally
and to brief against the eu in the way
that they have this week encouraging the
prime minister to to act like he's acted
on ukraine in relation to um the
protocol
and urging him to rip it up
that kind of aggressive language does
nothing uh to move us forward on what is
a difficult issue you and i have spoken
about the fallout from brexit on the
island of ireland before that we've just
had an election in northern ireland
which was a difficult election it was a
polarizing election
and the challenge for us all is to
listen to all communities unionists and
nationalists and people who don't
describe themselves as either
and try to ensure that the agreements
that we've signed in the past which is
now international law
is applied with the flexibility and the
pragmatism to respond to all of those
concerns as opposed to
legislating unilaterally
for the concerns of one community in
northern ireland which it seems to me is
what the british government is now
saying that they will do as soon as this
week
if the eu doesn't give them everything
they want so that is not the way to
approach a problem with a neighbor with
a friend and with allies and partners
which is what the uk has right across
the european union right now
you saying that um
about boris johnson shouldn't take the
same approach with the protocol as he
did with ukraine what exactly did you
mean by that well what i mean by that is
that uh lord trust who of course was the
the former negotiator on brexit issues
who was uh one of the architects of the
northern ireland protocol and the
withdrawal agreement which allowed the
uk to leave the eu in a structured and
managed way and he did a good job in
many ways for the uk but he on the front
of the telegraph this week urging the
prime minister to show the leadership
that he's shown on ukraine and to rip up
the northern ireland protocol i mean
what we are getting there is a senior
figure in the conservative party calling
on his prime minister to break
international law and to create huge
problems uh for britain's neighbor here
in ireland
and of course unnecessary tension with
the eu
at a time when we all need to be working
together to solve problems not least of
course in ukraine uh there are almost 30
000 ukrainians have come to ireland so
far seeking refuge and safety from uh
from the war in ukraine five and a half
million
across the eu
and we have huge challenges to overcome
together the idea that we would ratchet
up the tension on something else an
issue that we've been dealing with now
for six years which is the decision of
the people of the united kingdom to
leave the european union and all that
flows from that in terms of disruption
and tension
uh that we would ratchet that up now to
to new heights is deeply unhelpful
particularly when the eu
wants to actually continue to negotiate
wants to show flexibility at once to
compromise to actually recognize that
there are legitimate concerns held
within the unionist community in
northern ireland that need a
comprehensive response the primary one
being that we need to treat goods that
are staying in northern ireland
differently to goods that are at risk of
traveling on through northern ireland
into the eu and the eu single market and
the eu is willing to do that and
dramatically change the number of checks
on those goods if they can find a
partner in london to do it with them so
liz trust the foreign secretary says the
current eu proposals failed to properly
address the real issues affecting
northern ireland and in some cases would
take us backwards and if you look at
what some of what the uk wants you know
as you're talking about there changing
the burden of proof for goods remaining
in northern ireland expanding the
trusted trader policy simplifying the
process so traders have to provide less
information perhaps action on grace
periods and vat
can you understand some of the
frustration in westminster
that they believe that the eu has been
heavy-handed in imposing some of these
checks in a very very delicate as you
know of course
border in the irish sea uh the dp
currently refusing uh to set up a power
sharing arrangement in northern ireland
so time really is of the essence can you
understand some of the frustration in
the in westminster at
what they would perceive as a reluctance
from the eu to act decisively or quickly
enough
so can i tell you i've been in these
discussions for more than five years now
uh i have been in negotiations with i
think four or five different brexit
ministers
on behalf of the british government and
all good people
um but let me tell you ireland is also
frustrated
we are dealing with the consequences now
of a decision by the british people on
our own country that's cost us hundreds
of millions of euros that is risking the
peace process and its institutions on
the island of ireland
and so you know when we focus on
frustrations
uh we need to think beyond westminster
yes of course liz trust and she's a good
person and i know her well uh she wants
to see changes in terms of how the
protocol is implemented
and she is perfectly entitled to seek
those changes she has a partner in mar
sefkovic who's the vice president of the
european commission who wants to do that
with her but there's no way the eu can
compromise if the if the uk is
threatening unilateral action to pass
domestic legislation to set aside
international obligations under an
international treaty that don't forget
the uk was the primary designer of
along with with the eu so yes i
understand the frustrations and in
particular i understand the frustrations
in the unionist community i've spoken to
many unionists who want to see
pragmatism and real flexibility so the
trade within the united kingdom in other
words trade between great britain and
northern ireland uh is not disrupted in
any way that is not absolutely necessary
and we can get there to a landing zone
if we work in partnership but you know
saber rattling and grandstanding um
in westminster ratcheting up tension is
not the way to do it
and what i am saying and i've invited uh
uh liz trust to to come to dublin to
talk to me in detail about those
concerns i've offered to come to london
in fact i've come to london many times
on these issues i think mars stephanie
is in the same position but look at a
time when the world needs the western
world to be united
to be acting in concert
um to solve problems together
this is a problem we need to solve
together the last thing ireland wants
the last thing the eu needs is tension
with a country the size and the
influence of the united kingdom so let's
work together through the summer get
these issues resolved get the
institutions back up and running in
northern ireland which is
the northern ireland one the final thing
i'd say is sophie that um you know there
is an impression often across the united
kingdom that northern ireland is deeply
unhappy with the protocol and that a
majority of people want to change that
is simply not true the majority of
people in northern ireland have just
voted for candidates that actually are
in favor of the protocol because of how
it manages the disruption of brexit 53
out of the 90 mlas that were elected in
northern ireland would vote in favor of
the protocol tomorrow if asked to do so
what they want
is pragmatism and flexibility in terms
of how it's implemented that's what the
eu wants to offer that's what dublin
wants to help facilitate and i hope
that's what the british government will
work with us on in the weeks ahead yeah
which is the point that i made to quasi
quoting about the majority on the
northern lined assembly i just wanted to
quickly come back on you said there that
you had sent an invitation to liz trust
to meet has she responded to that
invitation
well look i mean we're we're talking
again on monday evening um i mean you
know i know this trust very well we we
shared other briefs uh that were similar
in in the irish and british governments
in the past we'll speak again on monday
um you know this is such an important
issue for ireland that i am available at
short notice to come to london or
anywhere else quite frankly to try and
work through these issues and you're
picking up are you picking up any
difference in tone between liz truss who
some
say in the press briefings here is more
strident and the prime minister who it's
briefed as more conciliatory in his tone
is is there a split there from what you
what you sense
well look you know i i want to be
careful not to comment on
the approach of british politics between
number 10 and and others in cabinet you
know all i can say is there is a landing
zone and a solution that we can get to
here if there is
a real partnership in terms of trying to
solve these problems um some of what's
been said this week by various members
of the british cabinet is unhelpful in
terms of helping us to get there but
there is an opportunity i hope in the
next few days to get this dialogue back
on track and to avoid
uh the the creation of a lot of
unnecessary tension uh by by publishing
uh unilateral legislation that would
uh send headlines around the world that
the united kingdom is deliberately
breaking international law and creating
huge tension with their closest
neighbors and potentially undermining a
peace process by doing that and if the
uk government
if the uk did act unilaterally
um without the agreement of the eu i'm
interested to know how the eu would
respond would you take legal action
could we see the imposition
of tariffs as a result
well i mean the eu has already
taken legal action because the protocol
isn't being implemented and the uk has
decided unilaterally to put in place
grace periods and so on but the eu in an
effort to try to build partnership set
aside that legal action they've frozen
it uh in an effort to try to negotiate a
sensible way forward and you know see
terrorism if
that's an indication of where the eu is
on this space
you know people need to look at that the
eu isn't threatening anything and i
think for us to focus on how the eu
would respond to the british government
deliberately breaching international law
is probably where we shouldn't be right
now instead we need to be trying to
avoid that situation but i think
everybody understands uh if the
uh if the british government decides to
set aside international law to create
significant uncertainty on the island of
ireland in terms of single market
membership and a whole range of other
things well then of course there's a
consequence the eu is forced to respond
but that is not where we want to be
where we want to be is good neighbors
good friends and solving problems
together and i would encourage the
influencers within the british
government to ensure that that's the
course that they decided the eu would be
forced to respond but i'm still just
unclear on what what that response would
be would it be yes i don't think you are
unclear actually but i i'm not here this
morning to talk about understanding um
uh the ratcheting up of tension i'm here
this morning to try to find solutions
and that's where i hope the british
government will be this week as well and
just very finally you know as you say
you know we have spoken
numerous times over the last few years
on brexit-related things it does strike
me this morning that you do seem
particularly frustrated i guess as a
word uh perhaps even even angry would
that be a fair summary of of where your
head is at right now well i mean i think
you know if you look at the comments
that i've made this week at the comments
that the t-shirt has made this week you
know we are both
friends of britain you know um
england and britain have shaped who i am
who many in the irish cabinet are you
know many of my family are uh are
british citizens um
some of my family work
and employ a lot of people across the uk
i've been to university in england there
isn't an anti-british bone in my body
quite the opposite but what i see at the
moment is a british government
making statements briefing against the
eu
and creating a lot of tension in my
country your closest neighbor and also
potentially
being on the verge of making a decision
that could fundamentally undermine the
functioning of the institutions of the
peace process in northern ireland let's
not forget this is not only about
unionism of course it needs to be partly
about union unionism but a majority of
people in northern ireland voted against
brexit and would vote against brexit
again in the morning if it was put to
them a majority of people in northern
ireland are in favor of the protocol
because they see that it does a
reasonable job to manage the disruption
of brexit in in the irish circumstances
there is a minority a large minority
within unionism who are unhappy with the
protocol there are solutions that we can
put in place that can ease that concern
and that's what we need to focus on
doing together
as opposed to the british government
acting on its own illegally in a way
that doesn't reflect majority opinion in
northern ireland and perhaps most
importantly sends a message to the world
that this british government when it
suits them will set aside international
law i don't say things like that lightly
i mean my job is to be a diplomat i'm a
foreign minister i'm a defense minister
and i want a really good relationship
with my closest neighbor
but what's happening at the moment has
forced ireland into taking a much more
strident position
and responding honestly uh to the
uh unhelpful briefings that we're
getting from very very senior levels
within the british government this week
which seems to be laying the groundwork
for a decision which i believe
could be deeply harmful for the
relationship between britain and ireland
uh if we don't see sense in the next few
days
okay simon coveney thank you very much
for being on the program this morning
simon comey